we are heading into another season of  The Voice and while new coaches Miley  Cyrus and Alicia Keys joined the pack  after 11 cycles Adam Levine and Blake  Shelton well they're still there and it  doesn't sound they'll be giving up their  red chairs anytime soon speaking at  Tuesday's TCA press corps session NBC  chairman Robert Greenblatt joked they  love doing the show and they love the  paycheck Adam and Blake have been the  two constants along with host Carson  Daly Greenblatt explained if I can  compare it to a scripted show you kind  of have your series regulars that you  love we think they're the pillars of the  show Shelton set the record straight  about their future on the show in May  with Kathie Lee and Hoda yes I'm staying  there of course I'm gonna study more on  us coming back to the bromance continues